the third piece of my plan
is keeping and maybe most important is
keeping our children safe and our
schools open
for any parent
it doesn't matter how low the risk of
any illness or accident is when it comes
to your child or grandchild
trust me i know
so
let me speak to you directly
let me speak to you directly to help
ease some of your worries
it comes down to two separate
categories children ages 12 and older
who are eligible for a vaccine now
and children ages 11 and under who are
not yet eligible
the safest thing for your child 12 and
older
is to get them vaccinated
they get vaccinated for a lot of things
that's it get them vaccinated
as with adults almost all the serious
covenant cases we're seeing among
adolescents are an unvaccinated 12 to 17
year olds an age group that lags behind
in vaccination rates
so parents
please get your teenager vaccinated
what about children under the age of 12
who can't get vaccinated yet
well
the best way for a parent to protect
their child under the age of 12 starts
at home
every parent
every teen sibling
every caregiver around them
should be vaccinated
children have four times higher chance
of getting hospitalized if they live in
a state
with low vaccination rates rather than
states with high vaccination
rates now if you're a parent of a young
child
you're wondering when will it be when
will it be the vaccine available for
them
i strongly support independent
scientific review
for vaccine uses for children under 12.
we can't take shortcuts for that
scientific work
but i've made it clear i will do
everything within my power
to support the fda with any resource it
needs to continue to do this as safely
and as quickly as possible
and our nation's top doctors are
committed to keeping the public at large
updated on the process so parents can
plan